hi everyone
um my name is Tom Drew relatively little
is known about one of Tesla's most
powerful Executives Tom Drew was Tesla's
Chief in China in the Asia region and he
led the construction in operation of
gigafactory Shanghai he's been so
impressive that in April 2023 Elon gave
him a huge promotion to senior vice
president of Automotive where he's
responsible for overseeing operations
worldwide including all of Tesla's
assembly plants this makes drew the
highest profile executive after Elon
Musk according to Reuters which reports
that those answering to Drew include the
director of manufacturing at Giga Texas
the senior director of vehicle
operations and Manufacturing engineering
at the Fremont Factory the Vice
President in charge of Europe Middle
East and Africa and the VP of sales and
service in North America the 43 year old
who hails from Beijing obtained a
bachelor of Commerce in Information
Technology from the Auckland University
of Technology in New Zealand he then
moved on to work at engineering
consultancy kibo engineering founded by
a Duke University MBA classmate The Firm
offers expertise to Chinese contractors
wanting to expand infrastructure
projects overseas while working for kibo
in North Africa he was reportedly
introduced to Cal Langton the then
director of Tesla's Global EV charging
infrastructure impressed by his work
LinkedIn hired him to join Tesla in 2014
to build that Tesla's supercharging
Network in China Zhu has been
responsible for Tesla's tremendous
growth in that region Giga Shanghai went
from a bare field in January 2019 to a
fully built Factory in just nine months
and delivered its first vehicle in
December of the same year that's despite
battling typhoons that hit the plant's
drainage system Zhu and other Tesla
employees took matters into their own
hands and went up to the roof to
manually drain the water with buckets
who documents the development of Tesla's
Shanghai plant on his YouTube channel
posted footage showing the aftermath of
the destruction Jew played a significant
role in the quick recovery of the
Shanghai Factory after covid lockdowns
in China halted production for many
companies and when a covid surge led to
a two-month lockdown Zhu is reported to
have slept in the factory the entire
time safeguarding its operations on the
rare occasion he isn't at the factory
Drew resides in a two-bedroom public
rental housing unit a 10-minute drive
from Giga Shanghai and costs less than
two thousand Yuan or less than 280
dollars a month according to Chinese
media Jews parents have come to stay
with them he keeps his private life
private but we do know he also has a
young son interestingly the apartment
complex is a residential area for other
Tesla employees which he revealed in an
interview with the Chinese car review
website PC Auto
it's a great atmosphere say you helped
me get my parcel oh I get something for
you it's a good way of working and
living he says he carpools with
employees to the gigafactory and starts
work at six or seven a.m in order to
catch his colleagues in North America
before they head home for the day that
includes communicating directly with
Elon Musk he spends the rest of his time
on the production line talking with
Engineers to solve technical problems
and often doesn't log off until midnight
on his Chinese social media account
weibo he posted this I want to sleep so
much but the job is so damn interesting
Drew's hard work has paid off he's made
Giga Shanghai Tesla's most efficient
Factory its annual production capacity
is over 750 000 Vehicles which is more
than half of Tesla's entire Global
Production of 1.37 million vehicles in
2022 Giga Shanghai can currently produce
one vehicle in less than two minutes
that's still not good enough Drew says
the goal is to have a Tesla rolling off
the assembly line every 40 5 Seconds
Shanghai achieved its productivity by
designing the factory in a straight line
layout which simplifies the flow of
materials through the manufacturing
process increasing efficiency it also
has a robust in-house construction team
to avoid relying too much on third-party
contractors and the third factor is hard
work thank you for being here late at
night Elon showed his appreciation for
Tesla's China team when he visited the
country for the first time in three
years in May 2023 and I tell people in
in you know throughout the world the
cars we produce here are
not just the most efficient
production but also the highest quality
I would like to just uh very much
congratulate you on the amazing work
that you've done and I just want to let
you know it's like
that's
it warms my heart you know
the Chinese government is a strong
supporter of Tesla which was the first
foreign automaker to open an independent
Factory in China usually foreign car
makers must team up with a Chinese
partner but some Wonder of Tesla's
position might be impacted by the
escalating tensions between the United
States and China
um I think you know as long as we're
needed in this country I don't see the
much of the risk of that
as big Ambitions for Tesla to grow even
faster in China and around the world it
took 12 years for Tesla to build 1
million Vehicles one and a half years to
build its second 11 months to build its
third and only seven months later it
built its fourth so we're getting better
at a faster exponential growth in an
interview with his alma mater or Duke
University he described himself as
tenacious and for his tenacity he's been
handsomely rewarded recently acquiring
an additional 339 060 shares in Tesla
according to an SCC filing given a share
price of 214 dollars when this video was
made they're worth around 70 million but
for Jew it doesn't appear to be about
the money but the mission until all the
cars on the road are electric cars we
will not stop
if you're inspired by Tom Drew's work in
managing one of the most sophisticated
and efficient Automotive factories in
the world you might be interested in
boosting your understanding of science
technology engineering and math that's
why I enjoy using brilliant the website
and app where you can learn stem
interactively my viewers especially love
Brilliance computer science courses that
can help you stay ahead in today's
competitive Marketplace there's
something for everyone whether you're
just starting out or if you'd like to
progress to more advanced courses I
personally enjoy going through
Brilliance logic puzzles to improve my
analytical thinking you can try out
brilliant for free for 30 days by
heading to the custom link in my
description
brilliant.org newsthink in the first 200
people who sign up with my link will get
20 off your premium subscription which
gives you access to all the offerings
thanks for watching I'm Cindy Palm